eq stéphanie vie hier économise bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france
les prévisions ne sont pas bonnes 1
selon bruno le maire de la france qui
aurait donc sa forte sa plus forte
récession depuis 1945 est ce que vous
vous partagez ce constat alarmant oui
alors si on regarde effectivement sur
grande échelle on voit que la france
n'avait pas connu une croissance en deçà
de 2% sauf lors de la période de 2008 où
la croissance était descendu à moins de
2,2 pour cent
et puis si on regarde les chiffres des
estimations de l'insee
on voit bien que il nous explique un
mois de confinement ça correspond à 3
points de pib en moins pour la
croissance annuelle déjà on peut se dire
que on va on va vraisemblablement en fin
d'année enregistré des taux de
croissance aux alentours de -3%
ça veut dire que le salut fis y en a
encore un viendrait d'une durée de
confinement moins longue
c'est à dire que plus le confinement qui
eux
en fait ce signifie à un appareil d'une
grande partie de la production française
est plus d'euros financera long et plus
effectivement il y aura un impact sur la
croissance à venir et puis en plus le
déconfinement 1 2 on le sait bien
aujourd'hui va être progressif
ça va pas être aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on va pas se mettre du jour au
lendemain à reprendre le travail et ça
va être par par étapes plus ou moins par
région et aussi par secteur donc tout ça
va mettre du temps et sans rame une
incidence sur l'économie donc la durée
de 2 du confinement est aussi
la mise en oeuvre du retour à la normale
est important à connaître pour
identifier exactement
en fait l'impact direct sur la
croissance française aujourd'hui
peremans les gouvernements navigue à vue
où on s'en fout en tant qu'économie vous
vous sentez une stratégie assez pensé du
gouvernement alors déjà ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand même
c'est une situation totalement inédite
on est on a connu des guerres on a connu
des crises économiques ont actionné des
crises financières on n'a jamais connu
et là c'est pas uniquement la france et
l'ensemble des pays développés qui
subissent le confinement
on n'a jamais connu un une une mise en
pause de l'économie avec décidée par les
autorités publiques
alors ça il est très difficile de deux
d'estimer le coût que cela représente
parce que déjà ça ne s'est jamais
produit par le passé et aussi parce que
là encore je reviens sur mon poids
premier point on sait pas combien de
temps ça va durer donc mais les mesures
déjà qu'ils ont été annoncés c'est
effectivement tenté au maximum de
limiter la casse 1 c'est à dire la prise
en charge par exemple du chômage du coût
du chômage partiel par l'état ça a été
annoncé par bruno le maire mais aussi la
garantie de l'état pour les prêts
bancaires à hauteur de 300 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises
donc c'est autant de mesures qui sont
prises pour essayer de d'amoindrir les
effets négatifs sur la croissance
économique
alors on se souvient évidemment de quoi
qu'il en coûte inde emmanuel macron
bruno le maire qui annonce 45 milliards
injectés par l'état donc en france
est-ce qu'on a les moyens justement de
ce quoi qu'il en coûte aujourd'hui dans
notre pays sachant que la dette est à
plus de 100 % 1 du pib alors ça c'est un
choc exogène de ce style on n'avait
guère
d'autres solutions que d'essayer de
limiter un code jeudi et pour ça et
effectivement l'état français mais comme
l'ensemble des autres états par exemple
de la zone euro vous revenir se financer
sur les marchés financiers c'est à dire
que l'endettement bas effectivement
gonflé aujourd'hui on est de l'ordre de
100% du pin
alors je parle de l'endettement français
ça va vraisemblablement montée mais est
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en face on
a quand même une banque centrale
européenne qui a aussi à envoyer un
message très clair c'est à dire que lé
là pour maintenir la stabilité
financière des états c'est-à-dire
qu'elle va récupérer prendre à sa charge
une partie du risque
un qui a été émis à travers la dette des
entreprises c'est à dire qu'en gros elle
elle assure que les taux d'intérêt qui
vont être imposés à chaque état pour cet
endettement ne va pas exploser ça sera
des taux d'intérêt très faibles
aujourd'hui à beaucoup de français qui
souffrent ont plané beaucoup de secteurs
où d'ailleurs dont l'hôpital qui peuvent
peut être légitimement se dire bah
finalement quand on on veut de l'argent
on le trouve dans certaines
structuration quelle est la réaction de
l'économiste non mais par rapport la cia
une bonne gestion globale de sur une
année 1 et on sait que à priori la bonne
gestion impose que les dépenses ne
soient pas supérieures aux recettes
et puis il ya à faire face à une
situation inédite un choc exogène qui
est ce choc center où il va bien falloir
en fait c'était le choix c'est au des
morts par par milliers a essayé de
stopper l'économie parce que c'était là
la seule solution alors après il y aura
bien sûr un
il y aura des démons va pouvoir voir ce
qui aurait dû être fait il ya quand même
des soucis on le voit déjà il ya eu un
manque de d'anticipation face à ce
problème là mais pas pour essayer de
limiter la casse et une étude américaine
qui a prouvé que finalement il valait
mieux confiné avec les risques que cela
peut avoir sur l'économie plutôt que
laisser l'économie tournait avec
effectivement un risque de mortalité qui
est quand même très élevé avec le commis
de 19
ces deux là aux alentours de 1 à 2% au
mieux de la population faites le calcul
1 2% de la population ça se compte en
france sur des lignes ont donc on ne
peut pas laisser ouvrir quelque part
dans un état et dans un pays développé
il n'y avait pas le choix que essayer de
trouver une solution dans l'urgence
effectivement ce confinement et après
trouver des solutions auprès des du
financement pour finalement ce qui
compte ça va être l'après crise c'est à
dire est ce que les entreprises
si l'épidémie va et arrive à être
endiguée parce que là aussi il ya un
donné qu'on ne connaît pas c'est le
traitement
c'est ainsi un traitement qui arrive est
bien plus vite il arrivera et plus nos
soucis seront seront atténuées donc il
ya aussi il ya quand même que gascoyne
de quoi espérer et en fonction de ça il
faut effectivement mettre les choses en
ordre de marche c'est à dire pour que
tout soit fait pour que l'économie après
une période d'arrêt puisse repartir le
plus rapidement possible et ça a été
notamment la décision du gouvernement de
prendre à sa charge le coût total que
peut représenter le chômage partiel
merci beaucoup stéphanie
vié économistes d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france